بعد اغلاق ابواب الجامعات امامها وامام
زميلاتها تفتتح حسناء مركزا للخياطه
والتطريز لتتعلم فيه هي وزميلاتها تقول
حسناء انها طالبه في جامعه كابول في السنه
الرابعه والاخيره وكانت ستتخرج هذا العام
التي تعيشها سيده الافغانيات فقد فتحت هذا
المركز لتشييع السيدات على العمل من جهه
والايجاد فرصه للعمل لهن من جهه اخرى
في الدراسه وفي العمل تقول لقد تم حرمانها
وزميلاتها من مواصله الدراسه في الجامعه
ولكي تقدم خدمات ولو بسيطه للشريحه
المظلومه من النساء بدات العمل في هذا
المركز
استقبلت رسائل مشجعه من زميلاتي في
الدراسه على بدء مشروع فخططت وانا مع
السيد حسناء افتحي هذا المركز لتقديم فرصه
تعليم الخياطه لفتيات وسيدات البلده حتى
يستطيعن التغلب على هذه الظروف الصعبه
التي يعشها عدد السيدات يصل في هذا المركز
حاليا الى 25 بين معلمه ومتعلمه يتناوبنا
على ثلاث ماكينات قديمه للخياطه والتي
تكلف كل واحده منها 20 دولارا وتشغل يدويا
بطريقه تقليديه صعبه
تقول سيدات في هذا المركز انهن يواجهن
تحديات اقتصاديه يصعب التغلب عليها في هذه
الظروف الصعبه ساعيات الى توسيعه انشطتهن
وذلك على الرغم من عدم تقديم دعم لهن حتى
الان عبد الله نادر العربيه كابول